所以這軟體很好用超用的
因為我每個月我就是靠這個軟體來做交易賺錢的嘛
這樣很恐怖的啊
這個量快16億啊
你知道16億什麼概念嗎
我們來看一下這個全證做得多呢
這邊呢會有這幾檔
這幾檔呢是今天盤中啦
各位記得喔
我們跟各位講一下
你盤中你打開喔
例如說9點開
它可能全部都是黑的
因为就你开那个全证做多的讯号一出来
他不会及时更新
各位你要记得他的机制
他的机制是这样子
就是你必须要再往下滑一下
往下滑呢
他就会更新最新的全证排行榜
所以各位你可以看一下
这全证做多
那今天这几个呢
是今天全证做多的名单
那这些全证做多名单呢
他有可能就会变成明天做空的名单
所以各位这个你可以去研究一下他的筹码
那我们跟各位讲
你盘充
做多的当充的方法
跟各位讲
你可以找全正做多的来做多
你也可以找组头买进的啊
组头买颜上轨的啊
这边都可以
你要找做多的
你可以从这边找
飙风向上股
你可以找这些来做多
那跟各位讲
我现在呢
我最喜欢的排序是这个
联亮排序
因为我的这个观察的股票比较多
所以呢
我现在喜欢联亮排序
以前我是联赤排序啦
但是观察股票太多了
联赤排序
我就必须看上面跟下面嘛
我现在直接看联亮
連量有個好處
它會直接按那個成交量
這個連續量的排序
那連續量的排序喔
你可以這樣想
假如第一筆就大量的話
它就是發動
再跟各位講
第一次大量它是發動量
那假如是第10次第20次很大量
那個就準備是轉折量
再講一次喔
第一次大量它是發動量嘛
那假如連20次
然後你又看到它急拉呢
那個就是轉折量
所以呢我們可以從這邊呢
可以抓轉折
那你做多的话
你可以找第一笔第一次的大量进场
或者你可以找连绿次连绿量爆量
就这两个绿色都爆量
代表它往下击杀
这时候你抓转折做多
做多有这方法
那做空呢你就要挑落势股
这边有落势股可以挑
那落势股呢
它就有今天呢这个全震是卖出的
各位你看今天这个全震卖出的
今天像这个友达
哇今天全震卖它就比较弱
新唐 新唐主委我們講他有全正賣壓嘛
他今天就比較弱
你看這個全正賣壓我們很喜歡做這個到9點半
那你可以看上面啊
今天大盤很弱 台子期很弱
那我們就是去找弱勢股來做空
你可以找弱勢股
然後呢 第一次的連量的大單進場
因為他是第一筆單
或者是你去找那個吉拉買盤捷徑抓轉折
也可以
所以這軟體很好用超好用的
因為我每個月我就是靠這個軟體來做交易賺錢了嘛
我都每個月貼對方案給你看
而且我們都做的量超大好不好
這個我做的量啊
各位你看一下這個量
這個量很恐怖的啊
這個量快16億啊
你知道16億什麼概念嗎
16億啊就是假設你是找我們的群組營業員開戶的話
16億呢你大概還可以退到
160萬就我這個月我都不要賺錢我就讓它損益是0就好了我剛退用就有退到160就這樣就叫16億那這個我們就是在抓轉折了
那我們再跟各位講
當衝做做第一次
你可以找主頭買中投進第一天到買股票
所以各位呢你可以找這裡
你可以找這種強勢股
主頭買
你可以找這些主頭買的股票
那這種線型呢你可以點進去看啦
可以看K線
K線這邊都有
這邊有這個投信買賣鈔喔
這邊有投信買賣鈔
你選投信買鈔
那我們很喜歡那種第一天買的
這已經買很多天了
我喜歡找第一天買的
所以各位呢你可以找我看
哇這主投買的
系統店,系統店第一天買
看起來還不錯
這投信第一天買,主投買
我喜歡找投信第一天買的股票
第一天大盤股票总是比较有点机会啦
所以呢各位呢你可以这样子去找
盘东呢你可以找联红亮第一笔大安进场
卖盘捷径找买点
第二次呢你也可以找这种标凤向上股
我们来看一下标凤向上股今天选出来的股票哪些
那这个是今天收盘选的
各位我们来给客看
今天收盘选的这个
收盘选的这个宣德啊 宏乃
我宏乃都变标凤向上股了
这几个
那各位你可以看它的K线
为什么叫标凤向上
因为它长这样
我看那個會是銀行的
銀行的傣銀行的
會有一個傣銀行的
所以我現在只是想買
這個傣銀行
今天將會買
我去買
這個傣銀行的
是真正的
看我希望妳們出現
我可以抵辭
你是那樣的
我就說好
都剛剛都可以去買
那你說好
他就更新
他更新最新的名單
這名單真的很好用啊
你再用連次量排序
那用連次量排序呢
你就可以抓到一些轉折
就像今天
今天我空了一檔
給各位看我今天空了一檔
叫做6719
那這個呢為什麼空它
給各位看一下為什麼空它
6719是這樣子的
來看一下昨天的線型
昨天線型長這樣
那線型長這樣
那蠻好玩的
他呢所漲停
結果呢
這個我們在那個放空時戰課有教
這種叫做
他一邊鎖掌停鎖了之後
結果後面這個怎麼樣
後面這個被MSCI調整到貨
所以隔壁買到327張
他頭很痛好不好
他頭很大
但是鎖掌停居然被倒最後一筆
他們最恨最後一筆到貨的
所以昨天的隔壁是誰啊
凱基啊 頭很大
所以他必須要拉高出貨
他買超多啊
買到400多張
成績本還沒出貨
所以這個
這明天搞不好還有點機會
那這個呢
約到格衝
他就會怎麼樣
他就會拉高出貨
拉高出貨
那拉高出貨呢
他會怎麼拉
各位呢
你會在一個地方
我們看到買盤捷徑
來看一下
9點14分
這邊
我現在找一下
這個9點14分的
這影片給各位看一下
這個我今天呢
有稍微錄影一下
這邊這邊
欸
這裡
9點14分大概在這個位置99點6分不知道在我這邊9點14分
他這個有稍微出現一下
好我們看9點13分
他盤中就會這樣跳
各位我們盤中我是用連量排序
那你就看
長榮24一21的這個就是
爆很大量而且拉不大上去
所以這邊很容易見轉折喔
那剛好萬海呢是往下殺
往下殺的轉折快出現了
長榮是往上拉的轉折
所以各位我們是用連量排序
各位你記得用連量排序
連量排序比較好用
比較好用喔 連量排序
好 那你現在盤中看到
哇 這個長榮一直一直拉一直供
這種供太多次連次量
它事實上呢
就很容易買盤的捷徑
這邊很容易買盤捷徑
好 各位呢 我們暫停一下
我們看到立志上來了
立志第一筆就161張
哇塞這個是故意拉來出貨的
這個是故意拉來出貨的喔
立志是故意拉來出貨的
好所以呢你看喔
你看他第一筆
161張
第二筆191張
哇這個很明顯
191張很恐怖欸
因為立志是600多塊的
這191張這超大量喔
而且他的股本又不是很大
這搞到很大量
然後第三筆 它又上來 196 張
那立志這個我們就是準備
準備抓轉折的
各位你看 第四筆 第三筆
它已經排到這裡了 立志已經接著爬上來了
那我們本來就鎖定好立志準備空了
立志呢 第五筆203張
因為剛好這時候很多都在拉
第五筆203張 剛剛有出現到632塊
那個是高點 第五筆203張
那立志後面就掉下去了
因為它變綠色了
那例子呢 剛剛我們有看到出現的高價呢
就在這個地方 632
在9點14分的位置
他在這邊奮力一拉
所以呢 你在
9點這個
12 13分的時候
這邊有奮力一拉的痕跡
這就是純純的高檔出貨股
這邊
他就是要奮力一拉來出貨
這裡
這邊
他大單一敲
準備拉來出貨
這個就是連紅次連紅量爆量
好那什麼時候呢
是賣盤捷徑呢
賣捷徑大概在這位置
9點33分
所以各位呢我們可以來看一下影片
這個是我今天盤中
這個抓的9點33分
我們來看一下到這個位置
9點33分
好 這裡
好 好啦
9點30分 我們來看一下
這個32分了
32分了
欸 這是特升喔
這通常我很討厭漲停的啦
因為漲停它會一直固定不動
所以有時候漲停我會把這個
置選股也取消掉
我就不觀察它了
因為漲停了
你現在做什麼都不能做了
排隊也不是 不排隊也不是
好
那現在是9點32分
那待會立志呢
它就會出現在榜單裡面
假設你空了這段時間你都可以不用理他
不用理他 因為他都沒有出現在榜單
那待會我們就會看到立志浮上來那我這自權股我是故意選了很多檔我這邊自權股我今天自權股超多給各位看一下這是我今天自權股的名單
各位你看 這麼多
我今天自權股名單這麼多
你看 這麼多
我丟了一堆股票讓它去跑
那各位你盤中不用丟那麼多啦
你盤中你可以挑一些自權股
丟就好 我是故意丟這麼多的
丟這麼多來跑
反正我就看這個在上面比較特別的
好 例字有沒有看到 例字出來了
10次128
再611塊
好 什麼是連次連量呢
我再解釋一次
連一次呢 就是代表這5秒鐘
這5秒鐘
它的內盤成交量
假設綠色的
綠色代表內盤成交量幹掉外盤成交量
那內盤成交量就是賣的人幹掉買的人
賣的人的張數幹掉買的人的張數
這時候會有連綠次連綠量一次
那這個是611塊呢是連續10次
就是連續50秒囉
賣的力道比買的力道還要強
連續50秒
然後呢他已經128張也爆量了
所以這邊呢上下都框框起來了
所以這時候有沒有看到這邊是急殺
所以這個點呢很容易是一個
短線的慢盤減輕點
後面會反彈但是不曉得彈到哪裡
有可能會再殺低
但這個點呢你回補也是個不錯的點
你可以回補之後這樣想
這回補之後假設高原到底下是10塊
你可以再反彈4塊的時候
你再空
因為他會反彈大概0.382嘛
你可以這樣想
我大概反彈0.4倍的時候
這樣講
那14分的時候沒有亮燈
因為他大概5次就沒力了
那次5次就沒力了
這個10次呢他是有亮燈
一直到611,611就在這個點
9點32分
611在這個點
612破了611
這點
這邊呢
他有出現在上面
因為立志我有空
我這個點我就有回補了
11次150有沒有看到
所以這段時間啊
9點32分
我們可以從這邊拉給各位看
這段時間
它都是內盤成交量比較多
有沒有看到
這邊每5秒統計次
都是內盤成交量比較多
這個呢就很容易
再搭配擊殺
這很容易導致一個賣盤結信點
所以你空在上面的這個點
其實是好的回補點
那有的人會講
為什麼不回補在580
那是你收盤才知道會在580
你收盤才知道
你沒有收盤你不知道
你有可能這個點就是一個不錯的點
它有可能後面又上去
所以呢我們是抓
相對的高點跟低點
你可以反彈之後再空回來
後面再等待 也可以
因為這檔股票今天就很
看起來很像會開大獎
因為昨天噎到的隔日沖
噢 噢 噢 噢 那這個就這樣子
那天運跟敦泰我沒有
因為今天我沒有把天運跟敦泰放成自選股
所以沒有沒辦法給你看
因為有放自選股才可以
那這個是我今天盤中用手機錄影
錄下來給各位看的
那這檔剛好我也有做
所以跟各位講一下
分享一下这档的做法啦
那个是做空的
那做多的你就可以用这三个方法